nous passons à présent à une page
culture avec la deuxième édition de
trappes impro family lancé par la
compagnie à déclic théâtre et pour nous
en parler mélanie poquet bonsoir mélanie
sa deuxième édition de cette opération
trappe impro family et ça on remet ça
c'est pas de moi je rassure c'est le
slogan donc de cette deuxième édition
alors samedi soir à la merise 12 joueurs
deux coaches 3 arvier de quatre
musiciens amc vous allez me dire wilfrid
en fait c'est la recette traditionnelle
d'un match d'impro mais la différence
réside dans le titre le mieux c'est
quand même d'écouter nouvelle yakine
louise c'est le responsable du secteur
improvisations des compagnies et nous la
présente 700 riches
les comédiens de déclic théâtre
d'aujourd'hui et d'avant et les cousins
les amis
enfin les amis les cousins des autres
ligues je dirais voilà qui viennent
enrichir un petit peu notre casting
locale donc l'idée c'est d'avoir voilà
des membres des joueurs des épices de
l'équipe de trappes mais aussi des
comédiens de paris un pro de la leaf
hideux d'autres ligues parisienne et qui
sont pour beaucoup qui ont beaucoup fait
leurs armes un moment ou un autre ici à
trappes à saint quentin en yvelines et
parmi ceux d'avant des noms qui parlent
hills à doumbia je pense qu'on a même pu
elle présentait donc bien virer su se
faire sa place effectivement sur le plan
national serge emig ritaine jennie anne
walker sont aussi présents jules et
galibert laurent mazetti river l'escaut
et bien d'autres pas tous les noms on
laisse un peu de surprises aussi des
comédiens dont certains ont été
champions du monde qu'il qui le seront
plus tard on ne sait jamais d'autres qui
jouent dans des comédies musicales des
champions de beatbox des champions de
france et chanteur quoi faire
mélange de est discipliné de talent
forcément ce sera dinde un haut niveau
nour el dia qui ne me l'a dit c'est la
réalité de l'impro qui pourra le dire en
gros tout est question d'un pain
d'inspiration en fonction du thème donné
on ne sait jamais mais oui en effet
wilfried ça devrait assez vite est
sensationnel et en général le public à
la merise laurent bien aux comédiens
écoutez
l'improvisation ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on répond aussi au public que l'on
rencontre donc forcément on s'adaptera
et les gens seront s'adapter et puis
trappe c'est un peu une capitale de
l'improvisation en france donc les gens
savent que quand ils viennent à trappes
ils vont rencontrer un public qui qui
qui connaît l'improvisation qui a une
vraie culture de l'impro et du cou du
coup ça ne peut être que positive la
deuxième édition de trappes impro family
rendez vous samedi 8 octobre 20h30 ce
sera à la merise les renseignements le
détail sur le site internet de la merise
la mairie ce point com merci mélanie